the Joe Rogan experience and I don't
care about that sort of stuff you know
by all means make a full lesbian sized
film like it I don't I don't care about
that but you feel hectored like you feel
like someone's standing over your
shoulder saying you see that that is
what you're supposed to support you're
all Homer photos but that is that's good
right that's what they're basically
saying they're saying you're all bad
people just human beings they don't
trust society and they're rabid there
are rabid about their there their need
for compliance
everyone must comply there's a crazy one
that I I'll send it to send it to a
bunch of people about them calling for
Captain Marvel to step down right okay
why because I will we find it for your
because it's it's so [ __ ] ridiculous
they want Captain Marvel to step down
and be replaced by a gay woman of color
right yeah because I don't mean is that
how the comic book was originally that's
the original comic book of gay woman
well so no I'm not a comic book fan but
I know that they say something that's
particularly affected comic books in
terms of Thor element okay we need brie
Larson to step down from her role to
prove she's an ally of social justice
and ensure a gay woman of color plays
the role let Monica the original female
and all caps black Captain Marvel
instead of whitewashing characters for
the benefit of the straight white men
running Disney first of all Disney is
run by a woman this should be clarified
up I'm almost positive
the CEO of Entertainment Disney's a
woman is that right that pretty sure
that's true yeah they've still got Walt
on ice there haven't they he's still
yeah they've had okay is that no but
they'll do Entertainment CEO of there's
someone who runs the film division
Whitney Cummings is explaining it to me
about how ridiculous it is but isn't
bring nice and whoever makes the
decision isn't brie Larson super woke
like she's got a reputation of being
incredibly woke now walking off a few
white but she was the one he said that
she wanted to ban male journalist from a
press junkets and from maybe it Fox you
know I don't think either way I don't
think you can that reminds me of when a
you know Camille Palio the academic go
back to that she tries to ban male right
brie Larson made a speech about how she
wants she felt that there were too many
male critics assessing her work and she
wanted to actually implement some kind
of strategy to prevent that from
happening yeah it was all over the press
so she's she's about as woke as it gets
right enough she needs to step down
because if you really woke you'll step
down and show that you're an ally for
social justice and give up those
millions of dollars to some other person
but by the way well you know tell the
studio that you're gonna do that like
they're not gonna [ __ ] just decide oh
you want us to cast a black gay woman
let's do that and does it matter which
black gay woman a you know there's a
have to be someone who can act that
gayest black I said imagine fine because
if you have like a half black and kind
of gay like pansexual yeah then that
that's a part of the patriarchy right
that's okay that's a problem isn't it
it's like when Obama [ __ ] up people
blame it on his white side you know it's
like no because he's 50% white he's 50%
problematic you can never have the kind
of purity and the example is given with
Camille Pilate cause she's an academic
who was asked to step down by her own
students and they said you need to reply
faculty you need to replace her with a
queer woman of color like who why does a
woman have to be queer why if you want a
woman of color like you see this is the
thing it never ends
you can't be woken up and once it gets
too queer woman of color and they've got
one of those ago you know what you
should make room for a transgender and
what if the queer woman of color is
really bad at her job - my bad it
doesn't matter adapt you need to help
her right okay I understand the society
has [ __ ] her over and that's why she's
not as good as Camille Paglia was so
again it gets back to one of those
fundamental premises that they don't
believe in objective truth they think
objectively this is a postmodern thing
right they don't believe it it's also
these people that you're talking about
they haven't built these structures that
they want to tear down right right
they're not a part of the construction
of these enormous film studios enormous
entertaining entertainment Empire yeah
that's you know so they want to step in
to something that not only have they not
built but they're not capable of
building right because they're wrapped
up in this [ __ ] wacky ideology that
allow you to be creative so how do we
get out of it like a good question
that's why I brought you in you know
well I've got ideas yeah I've got a few
ideas right because because I think I
think we're reaching a kind of tipping
point like I say like there's so many
people who were really sick of it you
know
[Applause]